a lot of the YouTubers that'll watch
will be like whenever they talk about
somebody that they're they're arguing
with or that they disagree with they say
don't contact this person anything you
say to them that is not 110 percent
affirmation of everything they believe
will be seen as an insult and as an
attack so they believe that anything
that is not 110 affirming every aspect
of who they are the decisions they've
made the person that they they've become
is somehow an attack on them as a person
when we understand that the world is not
that black and white and this is like a
lack of self-confidence though yes it is
doesn't that feel like if you don't
celebrate me then I must be doing
something wrong it's ridiculous and I
think I think one of the core problems
is that we've boiled all love down to
sort of this idolized worship often
rooted in sexuality you know what I mean
like I think we forget that there are
all kinds of ways to love someone and
support someone that doesn't mean that
you fall over backwards trying to say
that they're the best thing of all times
and everything they do is write write
all the time